[Music]
[Applause]
it's what should be and it gives me help
you know for the future we're still
lacking in stories that are driven by
women that are about women that are
directed by women I find that
extraordinary he became into a license
things kind of just they got bright
again the ghovat 19 outbreak began in
the Chinese city of Lu Han which still
has by far the largest number of cases
worldwide our Asia correspondent Tom
Cheshire has managed to speak to a
health care worker at a hospital inside
the quarantine zone every patient here
is suspected of having kovat 19
including Lee Xiao Zhang a 29 year old
local when we turn was locked down at
the end of January a city of 11 million
people quarantined miss Li started
volunteering that work was dangerous and
as a result miss Li got sick this is her
being tested for kovat 19 she
transmitted the infection to her parents
who are in a stable condition this is
the first time Miss Li has told the
truth of Wuhan and she's worried what's
the situation being like she wanted out
miss Lee says Wuhan has improved
significantly since then since we spoke
miss Lee's latest test for covet 19 came
back negative
shall stay here for a couple more days
then go home miss Lee's story her
despair her hope is just one among tens
of thousands of covet 19 cases
world renowned conservationist dr. Jane
Goodall has said coronaviruses probably
Nature's Way of fighting back against
the way animals are treated by humans I
went to meet her at the University of
Kent ahead of her lecture last night on
chimpanzees conservation and getting
young people involved in the environment
we don't just clarify that on our
coronavirus being--being nature fighting
back what do you mean oh because it's
said to have come from the Chinese habit
of eating wild animals and now they've
agreed to ban the meat market I mean
these meat markets terrible terrible
places animals crammed into tiny cages
and the viruses that come from the
animals call them Zune and do not x2
something rather and they can mutate and
become a virus that hurts us whereas
they kind of live in harmony with the
animals
what is the dire situation by your
definition some people talk about the
sixth mass extinction other people talk
about pollution what what for you is
there's the darkness of this situation
they're all intertwined that's the thing
I can't just take one piece and think
that you can solve anything with just
that one piece but luckily there's so
many people now joining this battle to
save the planet that you get people with
different expertise errs and my job is
really to present the general picture
which has resulted in this climate
crisis where'd you find the hope we are
beginning to come up with you know
innovative technological solutions that
will enable us to live in greater
harmony we need to get you know more
month behind solar wind and so on you
yourself are now vegan and people you
know look to you as a role model
should we stop eating meat should we all
go vegan well I'm not pure vegan I'm
vegan when I'm at home which is not
often but you know on the road it's
really difficult what do you feel about
extinction rebellion and the other
strikes that are going on how far in
pursuing environmental goals should
people go into
of disrupting other people's lives well
you know I think first of all it's been
really important to wake people up to
show that there are hundreds and
hundreds of people in young people out
there who truly care but it's not the
route that I personally I want to change
people's hearts and talk to them and you
know help them to want to change you use
the mainstream media you go to places
like Davos you know and never to admit
you end up mixing with people like
Donald Trump I mean did you I have not
mixed with Donald Trump we're at the
same place at the same time no he was
leaving as I came are you yes
I mean you are prepared to work with
people who are antithetical to you you
know when I first sat down with the
scientists who were using chimpanzees
and medical research putting them in
five foot by five foot cages to test
vaccines and so on and it was so
shocking to me so I organized a meeting
to meet with some of these lab people a
lot of the animal rights people who I
thought were my friends then refused to
speak to me because they said how could
you sit down with those people and said
if you don't sit down and talk with
people how can you expect them to change
I just wonder what sort of primate you
you see Boris Johnson as it seems rather
chimp like to me well quite honestly I
think comparing Boris or Trump to a
chimp was a little bit in something to
the chimp
Harvey Weinstein was today led out of
court in handcuffs and taken to jail
after being found guilty of sexual
assault and one charge of rape he was
acquitted of three more serious charges
but after the verdict the prosecutor
said it was now proven the one-time
Hollywood Titan was a sexual predator
over many years women alleging sexual
assault by Weinstein State's Island the
once allegation surface dozens came
forward he was correspondent Greg Marlin
there's been speaking to some of them in
Los Angeles the assaults they allege
happened too long ago to result in
criminal charge
but they see vindication in his
conviction is justice it's it's what
should be and it gives me help it feels
incredible it feels like one piece of
this terrible ordeal for so many women
so many people involved is at least in
one aspect put to rest so it feels it
feels like a victory feels like justice
is served as of five years ago it was
still a secret basically and to think
that now all these women have come
forward in the world is is taking note
and that he's actually facing you know
jail time is it means that we've really
come a long way
I don't think Harvey Weinstein ever
thought he'd see this day he did
everything in his power to keep it away
were the catalyst for this huge movement
the me to movement is bringing about a
lot of change a lot of conversation
about sexual assault about equity for
women and I'm grateful that my speaking
out along with these women has made a
difference it's kind of a moment of a
surge of reckoning in a way there's a
public dissection and of all of the
different aspects of sexual violence and
abuse of power a woman should never be
afraid to be alone with a man being a
teacher
the male plumber that comes to your
house
I mean the list goes on and on there is
we're just cultivating more fear and
then it's on the woman and we have to
just go around you know terrified we're
gonna be raped everywhere we go that's
that's not that's no no
that's not right at all not only did he
commit these crimes he got away with
them for so long and he harmed so many
of us I mean it's horrific if you think
about it he think about this little
piece of history it's hundreds of women
we have finally been heard and believed
and that is worth everything and I also
think it will send a message to
perpetrators everywhere that
consequences are real what do you think
of Harvey Weinstein now I'm very angry
at Harvey Weinstein because this man
assaulted me and got away with it so
many years ago and I'm angry that he
assaulted so many women I'm angry for
every single one of them I think he's
just disgusting vile criminal
all along Harvey Weinstein has denied
these allegations but it doesn't end
here for him he now faces another trial
in Los Angeles a city and an industry he
once ruled now the stage for the
continuing story of his fall from grace
military wives is the new film from
Sharon Hogan and Kristen that Scott
Thomas I've been talking to the stars
about their new movie but also
discussing the wider industry in light
of the Harvey Weinstein verdict let's
come up with some exciting activities to
do while our service people are away
what about singing singing uplifting and
there'll be a few beers afterwards I so
did it because of this one here I didn't
really know about the military wives
choir I read the script I despite it
incredibly moving I love the idea of
talking about people we don't talk much
about and I love the idea of the sort of
the choir being cathartic and also Peter
can tanio who directed it I think was a
big part of their reason as well because
what he did with the Full Monty I think
we both kind of felt like he could do
with this so wouldn't be too saccharine
or treacly he could sort of show an
authentic version of that world without
I mean you know it's definitely
heartwarming and it's well it made me
cry that's it but are you doing a way
that felt real no thank you
it's like childbirth that's to be
completely oblivious until it's
happening we are increasingly talking
about women and their experiences and
the obstacles that they face in your
eyes have things changed
I think they've changed they're changing
at a snail's pace but they are changing
you certainly see more women technicians
than you did 10-15 years ago we're still
lacking in stories that are driven by
women that are about women that are
directed by women I find that
extraordinary that we still have so few
women directors it's incredibly bizarre
because there's literally no reason for
it
no other than it's sort of considered
you know a man's world still but I mean
I think that's because
the people who who make the decisions
still I mean you know in charge of the
studios or the ones who control the
purse strings or are still predominantly
males a lot of female producers because
we're seeing this sort of we know as a
mothering kind of role isn't it like you
get everything together but the more you
know I mean we can we can hold cameras
they're not that heavy
you said the atmosphere on your set was
completely different because of the
amount of women do you think it the
atmosphere has changed more on sets
generally are women more likely to speak
up if they've got a problem with what's
happening or definitely and that needs
to be maintained and encouraged and as
you say not little take off the top of
the pedal yeah I mean I think we feel
far safer than we felt for a long time
lately but not just in this industry I
mean that's the thing it needs to be
sort of an all pervasive thing it needs
to sort of because it you know if it
happens in our film industry it's
happening and you know the factory down
the road and you know in a hospital or
you know it's it's sort of something
that everyone has to get involved in
rugby prides itself on inclusivity
regardless of gender size or sexuality
from the grassroots like these women in
North London to the elite level but now
rugby is wrestling the thorniest issue
in sports
how do transgender players those who
have switched from male to female or
vice versa fit in world rugby the
sport's governing body is concerned its
current eligibility rules could be
putting all the women at risk
they're holding a groundbreaking two-day
forum where scientists lawyers and
advocacy groups will debate the issue
Verity Smith continued to play for other
room ladies while transitioning to being
a man now he fears transgender players
could be excluded what would you say to
people who say in women's rugby it's
dangerous I don't think it's dangerous
as I say Sport is for everybody I've had
to play women they're over a foot taller
than me I've had to play women they're a
lot bigger size wise than me so why
would it be a danger we all go into spa
and probably specifically knowing it's a
contact sport and when you look at the
international games look at your
scrum-half look at your second rows over
a foot and a half difference sometimes
everybody needs to have their identity
and who they are so myself I played as a
gay female for many years my parents
died when I was young and rugby was the
one thing that I had in it was my one
constant many years ago I got told by
the brook we guidelines that if I came
out then I wouldn't be able to play
women's rugby and there wasn't any
policies to go play men's rugby at the
time so I've lost the majority of my
life not being able to be me and but for
the last three years I've got to live my
life as me and be my authentic self and
for anybody to be able to live their
lives and do the one thing that they
love everybody should be allowed to do
that no matter what their background is
[Music]
the Sophie was about a century away from
being invented when Bob Layton was born
in 1908 Bob is about to turn a hundred
and twelve so what is the secret to a
very long and healthy life that's what
everybody wants to know and I am the
slightest idea
good genes are address and taking things
has to come instead of worrying about
them for months I see a card from Her
Majesty the Queen so that's quite all of
us a year or two ago because I see no
point in her sending me one every year
for 10 years she's about most sensible
person in Britain everybody else is a
bit mad what do you make of modern life
I think there are some great drawbacks
the lack of actual personal contact add
to our contact everybody's walking down
the street hold them of these things a
bit of this to their surroundings and to
people who know it so they might walk by
each other without noticing who it was
and tell me over your life did you eat
or drink anything special was there any
foods you avoided or did you exercise a
lot I ate what was put in front of me
no questions asked Amit Patel was
working as a trauma doctor when a rare
condition caused him to lose his sight
within 36 hours after being assaulted
while using a white cane he hit rock
bottom but with the help of his guide
dog and [ __ ] he's managed to turn his
life around and has now written a book
about how his world has been changed
tell me about [ __ ] [ __ ] is the most
adorable blonde guide dog that I know
anyway she is she is she's I think she
was what was missing in my life in a
weird way when I lost my sights I never
really thought about a guide dog never
it never even crossed my mind
I didn't think I even thought that a dog
would ever change my life so much but
she kind of came in and she filled that
void that was missing and I think I'm a
better person for her being in my life
I've achieved so much more and
I'm kind of ready for the world for
whatever is you know whatever it's gonna
follow me tell me what happened to your
side so I had a hemorrhage in the back
of my eyes it was unexpected it wasn't
something that we prepared for when ii
went home after work one evening had
dinner where my wife went to sleep woke
up and had no sights when i wake up in
the morning so there was no there was no
pre-planning or anything it was
literally going from light to dark and
that was it
so it is either get on with life or what
be scared of the world and i'm guessing
you were scared for a while
for quite a while i don't think anything
could pay you for anything like that
it's everything you knew for me it was
it was because i'm sighted I could do
things I can get up I could be
independent but just to have more the
lights turn off and and not know where I
am even the basics even not navigating
my house walking in a straight line
making a cup of tea in the morning
looking at myself in the mirror it's
it's the things you don't really think
about that it's the small things that
you miss it's I would never see my wife
again I'll never see my parents I'll
never see my family it's it's something
that just can't you can't prepare for
but when it happens it put me in a very
dark place for such a long time because
I thought how could I move on how can I
live my life in a dark world but slowly
you know with the right people around me
you know my wife is amazing she she
never gave up hope that's you know I'll
find myself again and then [ __ ] came
into our lives and things kind of just
they got frightening that smile became a
genuine smile it wasn't a fake smile for
everybody else around me I know that you
put a body cam on to [ __ ] for a while
didn't you just do a highlight and
illustrate what happens on achieved
someone approached me and said eh you
okay and I said yes I'm fine I'm just
waiting for my guide dog to kind of find
their bearings and she explained that
someone had actually swiped an umbrella
in front of kickers face and that's why
[ __ ] stopped so I thought well they said
this is the reaction [ __ ]
does when someone does this it's
happened quite a few times I know she's
able to cope with the good and the bad
but for someone to actually consciously
take a swipe at a guide dog who's
guiding your video
person through a busy station because we
may have got in their way or they want
to get in front of us on an escalator
you know you just kind of think well
hold on you know we're only gonna
inconvenience you for about ten seconds
after that you can just walk past us but
she always you're cited life and they
carry embryo started life I think people
don't realize just how difficult it is
to navigate I'm sure [ __ ] and me you've
written tell me about it it's a book
that isn't all about sight loss it's
about my journey through sight loss but
it's about how people come together how
people don't give up on you it's about
what you can achieve even when you've
gone through something traumatic in your
life for me I personally thought my life
was over I I didn't think that I could
ever get back on my feet I'll hold my
head up high again and because I've
worked so hard being a doctor and I
thought while it's all been taken away
from me
but it's it's a story that it it brings
people together and I think I think it's
all about having good people around you
as well and not giving up